hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar overcoming sequence artifacts to
fuel clinically relevant ngs
applications
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by watchmaker genomics
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
zane jeffer senior scientist at
watchmaker genomics zane you may now
begin your presentation
thank you for the introduction and
thanks for everyone who's taking the
time to listen in
before we get started i'd like to take a
second to introduce watchmaker genomics
and the team of experts bringing this
presentation together
we're a life science company
headquartered in boulder colorado with
an r d facility in cape town south
africa we specialize in this in the
design development and production of
tools and toolkits that modify nucleic
acids and enable high-growth
applications in genomics molecular
diagnostics and personalized medicine
with experienced leadership our talented
team has made great use of the last two
and a half years since our founding and
we're excited to bring these high
performance products to the market
in recent decades we have all bore
witness to unprecedented advances in
genomics technology and have seen
academic industrial and clinical
genomics markets a lot evolve alongside
as costs decrease and throughput and
resolution increase sequencers are
moving toward becoming a universal
readout for biological information
sequencing is now being applied not only
to genomes or transcriptomes but to
understanding the dynamic epigenetic
landscapes of such samples
in addition various technologies are
appearing that allow the readout of
proteomic as well as pharmacologic
information
with so many important biological
signals converging on sequencing an
industry mission becomes ever more
pressing
the goal is to make the data recovered
from an instrument be a perfect
representation of the information
carried within the sample
capturing a sample sequence information
requires enzymatic manipulation at
multiple points from purification of the
sample to preparation on a slow cell
as a result data quality can only be as
good as the enzymatic reagents used to
process each sample
high quality reagents are necessary for
the development of highly sensitive
specific and robust sequencing based
assays if you control the enzymes you
control the information
this is particularly relevant when
considering the needs of clinical
sequencing applications over the past
decade the availability of higher
quality reagents has enabled the use of
lower quality samples and reduced input
amounts
clinical applications continue to push
the boundaries of existing ngs
technology and require reagents
specifically formulated to address unmet
performance needs sensitivity
specificity simple and scalable
workflows compatibility with a broad
range of sample types and vanishingly
small input amounts are necessary
performance characteristics of the next
generation of enzymatic tools for
genomics
watchmaker genomics is uniquely situated
to address these needs at the foundation
of our organization lies deep domain
expertise in enzyme manufacturing enzyme
engineering and computational biology
our ability to identify engineer and
manufacture enzymes at high purity
enables accurate assessment of enzyme
function and the ability to ideate
prototype and characterize their
function during rapid and dynamic
iterative cycles
focusing on application-specific variant
selection and reaction optimization
ensures that we're building tools for a
purpose rather than finding a purpose
for the tools that we build
our development strategy in simplified
terms
is to combine rigorous enzymology with
strategic experimental design our goal
is to harness the power of design of
experiment style experimentation and
couple it to ngs readouts to parallelize
our testing and by leveraging our
enzymatic and computational expertise
maximize insight
we start by finding evolving or
designing enzymes to fit in application
needs
these molecules and the reactions they
govern are often multi-step so in order
to really understand how they function
we assay individual activities in
addition to endpoint measurements
an example would be optimizing dna
polymerase activity in order to
understand variant performance we
independently monitor characteristics
like substrate affinity turnover rate
and specificity
that approach complex with doe style
buffer screening and highly multiplex
mgs readouts allows us to acquire
multi-dimensional and nucleotide
resolution insight into the critical
levers for tuning performance in each
reaction this sort of deep
characterization of a complex reaction
space provides us with an understanding
of the chemistry that allows us to be
agile during development and rapidly
customized based on users needs
one of our first exercises in applying
this strategy was focused on dna library
preparation
sonication is the gold standard for
unbiased robust dna fragmentation
unfortunately it requires a large
upfront investment in equipment and it's
not easily scaled to large sample
numbers and automation without increases
in overall processing time
generating libraries from low inputs
with this method is especially difficult
due to sample loss inherent to
processing and generally low sample
conversion rates of available library
preparation chemistries
related to some of these limitations
fornication-based library preparation
workflows have trouble fitting nicely
into the evolving paradigm of clinical
sequencing needs that i described
earlier
dna library preparation chemistries
based on enzymatic fragmentation are an
attractive alternative that alleviate
the monetary barrier to entry and
bottleneck of sequential sample
processing and automatability
however existing enzymatic
fragmentation-based chemistries are not
without their own limitations
particularly undesirable are increased
bias relative to fonication and the
introduction of sequencing artifacts
that result from use of previous or
existing products
any new enzymatic fragmentation based
product needs to successfully pair the
sequence accuracy and low bias of
sonication-based library prep with the
scalability and input compatibility of
enzymatic fragmentation based products
we saw an opportunity to leverage our
domain expertise and industry experience
to tackle this problem
we have specific performance goals in
mind
to lower bias
minimize artifacts generated during
library preparation deliver high
conversion efficiency as well as
maintain flexibility with respect to
input requirements for either high
quality dna or dna extracted from fixed
tissues
through the remainder of this section
i'll show you some of the data we
generated that supports the assertion
that we've done a pretty good job
accomplishing these goals
we ultimately developed the watchmaker
dna library prep kit with fragmentation
and the following key characteristics
and workflow details
our workflow incorporates an integrated
fragmentation and repair and a tailing
step followed by a same tube high
efficiency ligation reaction
this reaction is powered by a ligation
master mix built to improve liquid
handling and ease of automatability
pcr-free workflows can be finished in an
hour and a half of reaction time while
pcr based workflows require up to an
additional 30 minutes with an additional
b cleanup
our kit supports dna inputs from 500
nanograms to less than one nanogram with
consistent conversion rates and highly
tunable fragmentation for all input
amounts achieved just by adjusting the
time and or temperature of incubation
as i mentioned before our research and
development strategy is focused on
efficiently sampling a large reaction
space and understanding the multi-step
activities of enzymes we use
as a result we generate large data sets
that ideally report reaction optima as
well as reaction failures at extremes
our efforts optimizing for decreased gc
coverage bias is a great example of this
strategy with real utility for users
increases in uniform coverage ultimately
lead to increased sequence economy and
better data
shown here is normalized coverage data
from a series of pcr-free libraries
generated from human gdna
under different reaction conditions
modulating enzyme variants buffer
composition or the protocol
each coverage plot reports normalized
coverage on the y-axis as a function of
gc content on the x-axis
not only have we identified how to
minimize bias for the sample type we
better understand how to manipulate bias
in this reaction in either direction
from ideal
this type of comprehensive
characterization serves two purposes
one it allows us to quickly iterate and
customize product performance based on
future user needs
two it allows us to produce a base
product with desirable bias
characteristics relative to existing
products
shown here is a data set generated from
either our dna library prep kit and two
competitor kits
again we're reporting normalized
coverage data from samples generated
from high quality human gdna in this
particular experiment coverage plots
were generated from one nanogram of
input and prepared according to
manufacturer's recommendations including
pcr
what you see here is data showing that
while each kit performs similarly
through the bulk of the genome some
differences appear at gc extremes
overall our kit performs more
consistently with respect to gc coverage
bias and other related products
but what uses uniform coverage if a
significant portion of that incoming
data is not representative of the sample
itself the artifacts generated during
enzymatic fragmentation can at the very
least lead to lost data and increased
cost but at its worst create a very real
problem for clinical variant calling
chemeric reads are generated as either
authentic and likely clinically relevant
in vivo gene fusion events or during
library preparation when two fragmented
molecules molecules distant in linear
sequence but now broken apart and close
in 3d space are fused together
industry leaders have pointed to these
types of artifacts creating problems for
variant calling because it's sometimes
difficult to determine which of the two
causes is at play
in fact it's been pointed out that the
number of chimeras reported in libraries
prepared by enzymatic fragmentation may
be 10 times more than reported in
similar samples prepared by sonication
our kit virtually eliminates that excess
relative to sonicated samples
in the data shown here we have compared
the percentage of reads reported as
chimeras for either libraries prepared
by sonication-based prep our chemistry
or two competitor products under similar
circumstances our chemistry reports
chimera levels approaching that of
sonicated libraries a significant
improvement from other chemistries
processing of fragments during library
preparation often induces non-templated
or low fidelity polymerization of few
bases onto the end of library molecules
inflating the overall number of
mutations and decreasing overall assay
sensitivity
this sort of noise presents especially
large problems detecting low allele
frequency mutations
in addition groups have recently
excuse me groups recently have observed
a more complicated problem with these
types of n-localized artifacts
last year gregory adall presented an
analysis of the artifacts commonly
generated at the ends of reeds when
using enzymatic fragmentation-based kits
they suggest that with sufficient
sequence complementarity hairpins may
form at the ends of reads during the end
repair step that may be resolved into
sequenceable molecules through the
mechanism they proposed at the left of
this slide
regardless of the actual mechanisms that
drive this phenomenon this sort of
contaminating data ultimately manifests
as a problem shown at the right
when compared to libraries generated
from sonication in the blue overlay
enzymatic fragmentation based libraries
in red accumulate significantly higher
called variants shown on the y-axis as a
function of varying allele frequencies
shown on the x-axis notice how
enzymatically fragmented samples show a
much larger distribution of variants
below 10 variant allele frequency than
the sonicated samples
often noisy sequences like these at the
end of reads can automatically be
trimmed or soft-clicked during analysis
which may only create a problem for
sequence economy but every bit of
increased stringency of filtering runs
the risk of removing true positives
more concerning than the soft clip rates
are those reads that are not soft
clipped due to aligning to semi
palindromic palindromic sequences
these non-clipped reeds result in
inflated smvs and indel rates at the
ends of reeds due to the similar but not
identical sequence character of the
molecules they're derived from
therefore improvements in chemistry can
directly increase both sensitivity and
specificity of variant calling
members of our bioinformatics team
generated a similar artifact detection
tool as that used by gregory at all and
used it to visualize the frequency of
hairpin artifacts generated by our
chemistry
two competitors and compared them to
samples processed by sonication this
data is reported as a rate in the form
of artifacts per million fragments
again similar to sonication-based
library prep methods our chemistry
generates libraries with very few of
these artifacts each of which represents
a potential
potential false variant call
i've spoken about the importance of
decreasing bias and minimizing artifacts
in the context of variant calls as a
function of
improved chemistry but a similarly
important and straightforward path to
improve data quality is to capture a
higher percent of the input to begin
with
to that end we executed a head-to-head
comparison measuring the library yield
and found that our kit generates overall
higher yield than some competitors when
preparing libraries from either high
quality dna inputs or from formal and
compromised reference dna
the graph shown at the left reports the
concentration of libraries in nanomolar
on the y-axis
each sample was prepared in triplicate
from 25 nanograms of either high quality
gdna
moderately formally uncompromised or
severely formed uncompromised dna
samples
purchased from horizon discovery
yields are shown after six cycles of pcr
the electropharygrams on the right
illustrate consistent library sizing
among variable quality samples prepared
with our kit
our chemistry offers the performance
increases i just discussed but not at
the expense of highly desirable
characteristics like insert size
tunability and compatibility with a wide
range of inputs
tunable fragmentation is a key advantage
of sonication-based library preparation
and so ideally any enzymatic solution
should perform well in this respect
unfortunately the lack of tunable and
reproducible fragmentation has been a
pain point for many users of enzymatic
fragmentation even going so far as to
have great difficulty making libraries
with insert sizes at or greater than 500
base pairs
shown on the left are traces of
libraries prepared only with differing
fragmentation times
within this panel we show that not only
is insert size tunable from greater than
500 base pairs to less than 200 base
pairs fragmentation is consistent
between duplicate reactions
fragmentation is also consistent across
input amounts with acceptable ranges
spanning many orders of magnitude
the panel at the right shows overlaid
traces of libraries prepared in parallel
from 500 nanograms down to 0.1 nanogram
of input dna
in fact libraries can be generated from
inputs as low as one picogram of high
quality dna
using human human gdna as input we were
able to generate libraries from 1 000
kilograms to 1 picogram without a change
in library size
the libraries generated in this
experiment are not only sized
appropriately shown on the image on the
left but the vast majority of reads
aligned to the reference without
significant adapter contamination
illustrated by the graph on the right
overall our kit delivers high
performance at vanishingly low input
masses and expands the potential
application space for this product into
single cell territory
with such low sample inputs pcr is
required to generate sequencer-ready
libraries as a result a robust
high-fidelity library amplification
module is a necessary companion to our
library preparation kit
as i mentioned before errors in
sequencing data can come from any point
in the multi-step process from a cell to
a sequencer and many groups have
expended the effort to quantify the
extent and source of errors
one important source is the fidelity of
library amplification polymerases
a report earlier this year in genome
biology set out to quantify the error
rates of library amplification products
as well as
characterize error rates of individual
instruments at different institutions
in the figure shown in the leftmost
panel they report real performance
differences between the two high
fidelity polymerases kappa hifi and
neb's q5
with resulting error rates differing
multifold between these products
fidelity problems and library
amplification can sometimes be mitigated
through umi methodologies and error
correction algorithms however
sufficiently complex libraries or
libraries generated without uniform
amplification may result in many umi
families lacking sufficient depth to
make this correction possible
as a result any reduction in polymerase
errors is beneficial to the end user
following a similar strategy to library
prep we optimize for the fidelity of our
library amplification module
now in the context of pcr we
strategically investigated multiple
polymerase variants buffer components
cycling conditions and component
concentrations with a specific focus on
the fidelity of pcr amplification
shown at the right are polymerase error
rates parsed by specific type of base
substitutions
two important conclusions are to be
drawn from this experiment
first a subset of errors predominate
during library amplification
particularly a to g and c to t mutations
both may arise as a function of base
misincorporation and dna damage during
thermal cycling
second it is possible to reduce these
types of polymerase errors by the right
combination of polymerase variants and
reaction conditions
using this and many other data sets we
developed the equinox library
amplification master mix this product is
a robust and high fidelity library
amplification solution with usage and
performance similar to cap biosystems
hi-fi but with market increases in
fidelity and workflow compatibility
the first performance characteristic
i'll point to is overall library
amplification fidelity a direct result
of the development strategy i presented
on the previous slide
shown below is a comparison of the
polymerase error rates associated with
each base substitution for both equinox
and kava hifi
overall error rates are lower with
equinox and a particular performance
increase shows up with respect to a to g
and c to t mutations that i discussed on
the previous slide as well
relying on high fidelity amplification
systems allows high confidence calling
even when read depths are too low to
allow for error correction
in addition to exhibiting low error
rates a high quality amplification mix
must amplify uniformly
employing the use of a low input high
amplification umi-based model system we
investigated the amplification
characteristics of equinox kappa hifi
and attack dna polymerase 2x masterminds
in an ideal case no dna molecules and
associated umi families would be
inefficiently or preferentially
amplified that result would be that
after amplification all umi family sizes
would be evenly and tightly distributed
this is illustrated in the pink ideal
line on the graph shown
this analysis reports the cumulative
fraction of molecules or umi families on
the y-axis versus the full change from
mean umi family size shown on the x-axis
the more quickly a data set reaches one
the more uniform library amplification
is then
amplification with equinox in purple
leads to greater than eighty percent of
umi family depth independent of insert
gc content or length fall within two to
three folds of the mean umi family size
half a hifi also performs well as shown
in the green trace
for reference a poorly performing
polymerase test dna polymerase and nab's
2x attack master mix and orange in the
orange trace results in only 50 of umi
families falling within that range
with a focus on automation i'd like to
highlight a workflow improvement for
equinox one potential problem with
automated sample prep for pcr is the
stringency of hot start performance
high stability amplification mixes have
three prime to five prime exonuclease
activity necessary for polymerase
proofreading
unfortunately if not properly controlled
either by low reaction temperature or by
the hot start capability of a mixer
extended incubations for example long
setups for automated workflows
of amplification polymerases and primer
can lead to non-specific activation of
that activity and affect primer quality
any promiscuous decay of primer or
template 3 prime ends can lead to
decreased specificity of amplification
especially for low concentration samples
the hot start capabilities of equinox
inhibit not only the polymerase function
of the mix but also its exonuclease
activity
shown in the graph here is normalized
polymerase and exonuclease activity as
measured by
dntp incorporation or dnmp release
respectively
overall our economic equinox library
amplification master mix is capable of
highly specific highly uniform and high
fidelity amplification of ngs libraries
and is a great companion to our
enzymatic fragmentation based library
prep kit
at the outset of our development efforts
we have the goal of addressing some key
challenges in dna library preparation
we wanted to support the market by
developing products that maintain the
data quality of sonicated library prep
and the simplicity and scalability of
enzymatic library prep methods
what i presented here is performance
generated using either earth's
performance data generated either using
our watchmaker dna library prep kit with
fragmentation powered by equinox library
amplification
we have a straightforward and scalable
workflow with highly tunable
fragmentation compatibility with a huge
range of dna input amounts low coverage
bias and dramatically reduced sequencing
artifacts
these performance improvements bring us
one step closer to realizing the
industry's mission of making the data
out a perfect representation of the
sample company coming in
at watchmaker genomics we have a unique
and powerful perspective on how to
enable the evolving genomics market
our vertically integrated development
platform combines specifically
engineered enzymes into highly optimized
reaction systems and end-to-end workflow
solutions
we have the power to purpose build
applications driven tools for the
clinical space from the ground up
we're taking this novel platform and the
insights gained during development of
our initial enzymes reagents and
workflows and we're applying these
concepts to the next wave of watchmaker
grade products
keep an eye out for upcoming information
on our engineered reverse transcriptases
and rna-seq library preparation
development efforts
and with that i'd like to thank you for
your attention and open this up to
questions
thank you zane for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
how does library prep efficiency hybrid
artifacts
um yeah that's a great question uh
thanks for starting that off um i think
the the answer to that really comes from
uh kind of
two places i think the
the first thing is that not all um
molecules that are captured during
library prep are
um
uh generated with artifacts in them
and so catching more of the molecules
from an input that don't have any
artifacts or just having a more accurate
representation of the sample
is is good from that perspective so you
just have a greater chance of those
molecules ending up getting sequenced
in addition higher conversion rates
allow you to
decrease the number of or amount of pcr
number of cycles that you have to go
through
and also mitigate some of the potential
artifacts that generate from or that
come from that as well
okay thank you
um our next question is are there
differences in the way that ffpe
and high quality inputs are handled
yeah great great question um
so uh of course for anyone who works
with uh with dna extracted from
fixed tissues sample qualities coming
out can be quite variable
um
what it really means for compromise or
low quality versus high quality samples
is that the workflow is going to end up
being exactly the same
in terms of handling and steps and all
that sort of stuff
but what will likely have to happen is
that the the fragmentation
time or parameters may be modified
depending on the sample
and
that's that's ultimately the only point
i think where uh where that'll need to
be altered
all right thank you
um next question what is the minimum
input required for pcr free libraries
awesome um
so that's a bit of a nuanced question uh
just to uh to answer that a bit um
the
uh
i think
that very or depends a lot based on the
library size you're targeting um and as
well as whether or not you're looking to
multiplex or any sort of things like
that but generally speaking if you're
looking to sequence a single sample
we kind of recommend that if you're
looking for short libraries um or
libraries on the shorter end
that uh in the starting with 20 to 30
nanograms is usually pretty safe
um and if you're looking for very long
libraries something on the order of 40
to 50 nanograms and of course that's
going to vary by
some other things related to sample
quality and all that sort of stuff but
we we think that's a pretty good
starting place
all right thank you
next question
can you comment on performance of
fragmentation module with contaminants
such as edta or from crude extracts like
blood saliva etc
sure um
this product or the the
i guess library prep side is uh is
formulated in such a way that it um
accepts either uh you know water
standard trust buffers or
buffers containing up to 0.1 millimolar
edta in the
total sample coming with 0.1 molar edta
any problems or protocol adjustments or
anything like that
um with respect to
some contaminants
we have not done a lot of
thing on um those sorts of samples to
the sorts of crude samples let's say
um
but uh preliminary experimentation shows
that that our product actually works
pretty well with some
um with uh using cells uh as as input
um
or few cells as input but we don't
really know about the blood or saliva
but we do have plans to explore this a
little bit better in the uh in
the coming months um as we look a little
more into it
all right thank you
next question
does your polymerase extend across
uracil and dna
um
it does not
that would fit that need and i think if
you can
check in with our sales team then we can
get that to you
all right great thank you
next question
is this product compatible with inputs
in te buffer
um
it is i think with it depends on the
let's say the the strength of the te
buffer related to that um what i
mentioned earlier about edta
um and uh anything coming in with 0.1
xde is
it is perfectly uh works perfectly well
with
um
but again depending on the let's say
that the x of the the te then there may
be some uh
fragmentation time adjustments that need
to be made
okay
next question
are these optimization metrics all based
on illumina ngs data or have you looked
at your kit prep optimizations for the
ont platform
yeah so all of these uh performance
metrics and all this stuff that we're
talking about here is based on the
aluminum platform um we have not used
this product or this product is not
compatible with um the
um
with the nanopore platform um so
yeah let me get stuffy after
okay
um next question
what are the typical allele fractions of
artifactual variant calls
yeah um uh
so artifactual variant calls um usually
appear at low allele fractions and so
the publication that i referenced during
the talk reports most of these sorts of
artifacts appearing below five percent
or so um and ultimately what that means
is that these types of artifacts become
especially problematic when you're
trying to
trying to detect rare variants
okay thank you
um next why are chimeric fragments
problematic for data analysis
yeah um so
a chimeric bright i guess the there's
the data quality issues that i discussed
um during the talk um but in really
simple terms what uh aligning chimeras
um during during analysis uh actually is
a lot slower just because of how it has
to find i guess the position to find the
alignments so minimizing the the amount
of chimeras ultimately means that you
can process data faster
great thank you
um next question
can you generate less than six kb
libraries for long red sequencing with
this kit
um
it was not developed to do that um and
we haven't uh we haven't done any
testing on uh those uh at those sorts of
lengths um like i mentioned before this
was this is really just uh developed for
um use on illumina short read platform
all right
um next question
do you have
automation script or method already
developed for your library prep if so
for which liquid handler
yeah great question um uh unfortunately
we don't have anything specific uh right
now and uh we haven't worked on any
specific platform uh as of right now um
we do have some uh i guess some
relationships or some of our commercial
relationships that are uh we're starting
to work through stuff like that and i
think just um just to make the the point
i suppose
uh we're always happy to work with
um you or work with a customer on
facilitating that sort of um
developing those sorts of scripts
um
also just as a note any
if you already have
scripts or if there's already scripts
for whatever platform you're looking for
that that work with other
um similar types of library prep kits um
then those are generally good places to
start um
uh yeah i think that's the answer there
all right
um well thank you zane for your time
today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor watchmaker genomics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye